dans cet hôpital de marioupol les
patients sont évacués à la hâte les
autorités ukrainiennes accusé la russie
d'avoir frappé une partie du bâtiment
qui abritait de nombreux enfants
cette information a été confirmée
il s'agit de la maternité de l'hôpital
avec des nouveau-nés leur mère il y
avait plusieurs bombardements aériens et
le bâtiment a été détruit il ya de
nombreuses victimes parmi les enfants et
leurs mères
nous sommes en train de vérifier combien
de personnes ont été tuées
et combien ont été blessées
selon le maire adjoint de marioupol cet
hôpital n'a pas été bombardé par hasard
et se dote il s'agit de la troisième
clinique détruite par les russes
ils ont déjà bombardé le centre médical
non soigner les maladies bucco vide
[Musique]
c'était un hôpital avec 600 lits
ils ont aussi frappé le centre de
collecte du champ de marioupol
marioupol située dans le sud est de
l'ukraine est assiégée par l'armée russe
prendre le contrôle de cette ville
permettrait à moscou de faire le lien
entre les régions séparatistes du
donbass et la crime est annexée par la
russie en 2014
malgré plusieurs tentatives
impossible pour le moment de mettre en
place des couloirs humanitaires pour
évacuer marioupol près de 400 mille
civils sont toujours pris au piège dans
la ville où l'eau et l'électricité sont
coupées depuis déjà une semaine
championnat texte